so you play the Northern Trust you will
yeah so I'll play the Northern Trust
which I'm excited for it's at a new golf
course this year at Glen Oaks in Long
Island no one really has any experience
of it they don't know what to expect but
it looks beautiful I think then super
super Intendant Oakland Oaks was at
Augusta for a while and he's been in
charge of the two US Opens at Bath pH as
well so I'm expecting the golf course to
be in really good shape so yeah I'm
excited for that and obviously excited
for the next few weeks as well and
defending your championship at the FedEx
yeah defending defending the FedEx Cup
and I feel like I'm in a similar
position this year than I was you know
even last year I was 36 going into the
FedEx Cup playoffs this year I'm in the
40s but it's so volatile if you win one
of those event it was first couple of
events you you move up from 40th into
the top five and then you have a real
chance of winning the overall title so I
need to play well the next couple of
weeks give myself a chance and we'll see
how we go from there how's your health
my Health's good it's it's not quite as
good as it could be what is it what's
the it's an inflamed rib joint so it's
your CV joint connects your rib to your
vertebrae and there's just there's a
little inflammation in there is it pain
or does it affect your play it's more
pain it's not a it doesn't affect my
play it doesn't affect my swing it's
manageable it's totally fine I think
it's being blown up a lot more than what
it should have been I know you mentioned
that you're gonna play in the playoffs
and then take some time off that's the
most likely plan at the minute it's a
little bit up in the air but I'm gonna
play the FedEx Cup playoffs hopefully
play through the Tour Championship I'm
definitely gonna play in the dunghill
Lynx pro-am in st. Andrews with my dad
at the start of October
we've been year marking about one for a
while we're both really excited about
that and then after that I probably take
some time off I think it's it's the
necessary course of action to take if I
want to be 100% going into next season
going into Augusta going into Augusta as
well yeah yeah look gusta and the
Masters is a huge thing on my radar it's
it's the only major that I have left it
to complete the set and it's cool
knowing golf there's three people that
know I have a chance to win the career
grand slam
you know it's me at Augusta
Phil Mickelson at the US Open and then
jordan Spieth at the PGA so we all have
a chance of doing something pretty
pretty special and I'm joining that
elite group of guys there's only been
five guys ever to complete the career
Grand Slam and golf and there's three
current players right now that have a
chance to do that which is it's pretty
cool for the game if you look at your
game and if you take some time off at
the end of this year what parts of your
gained you really want to work on so I I
think my my golf game is built around my
my driving and on my longer arm play say
that's the where I again the bulk of my
strokes so for me it's wedge play and
specifically from 100 yards to 150 yards
that's something I really need to work
on and then in my putting I'm actually
pretty good from like inside of get feet
that that's a I'm pretty good I think
I'm like 72% right now on the PGA Tour
which is maybe in the top 20 so that's
pretty good but from from 10 feet putt
to like 20 feet or 10 to 25 that's where
I struggle I'm not there are two areas
in my game if I can improve that'll make
a huge difference going forward for me
and that's not new that's just always
been part of your game it's it's
sometimes it's there's other things
sometimes I've been a good wedge player
and my mid irons have been letting me
down or my long irons or so but there
are two aspects right now that are
glaringly obvious that if I can just
improve a little bit and devote a little
bit of time to if I can sharpen up in
those areas you know I feel like I'll
have a great run next year